the jurgen experience
i want to see what happens when joe
biden gets into office
i want to sleep a lot he'll nap i don't
see what the speeches are like when he
forgets what he's talking about he's
going to have no clue
kamala he'll run for return live for
he'll he'll
he'll live for a term hill it's kamala
and if you
pronounce it wrong you're racist i call
her k-dog
no she she's gonna run he'll he'll do
one term and then she'll run i don't
think he'll run for a second term
he's already too old he'll he'll do one
term she'll come in again no one will
care about politics she'll be yass
queening all over the place
if he does run for a second term he'll
be in his 80s
yeah he's not going to run for a second
term she'll she'll run she knows that
that's what she's pumped but do you
think they have to think that through
when they
when they run for president like if
you're 78 and you're barely hanging on
now it's probably unspoken but i think
that that's probably i think why he
picked her
is because she's everybody's been vital
yeah she everybody's kind of comfortable
with her she's a centrist
she's a cop right she doesn't care
she'll put you right in jail
she'll put the cuffs on you the
government the larger power centers are
very happy with her
that she'll throw him in the vans she'll
brand ya thank you
she runs who's her vp god only knows i
mean someone else that shares her values
which are
there it is aesthetic political action
all americans to wear masks
three months he says for three months he
was joined at briefing by his newly
named running mate
um let me hear it it's weird it's a long
speech it says this i want to hear some
of it i just want to hear his voice
okay here it goes give me some when one
arrives
and what plans to be made for we talked
about significant about the racial
disparities
that exist and how it is uh
covert 19 is affecting
different races differently and we
talked about the continued lack of
ppe protective equipment and uh
testing capacity and the like but uh
and uh i've put out a comprehensive plan
over the last
three months on each of these things but
today
i want to talk about one thing very
straightforward
doesn't have anything to do with
democrats republicans or independents
it has to do with a single simple
proposition
every single american should
be wearing a mask when they're outside
what for the next three months at a
minimum
every governor should mandate
every governor should mandate mandatory
mask wearing the estimates by the
experts are it will
save over 40 000
lives in the next three months
40 000 lives the people act responsibly
and uh it's not about your rights it's
about your responsibilities
as an american that's a bad line well
not a great line i i get what he's
saying
at least he got through that without
stumbling he seems to be getting better
they're they're
injecting him with something where he's
getting better yeah no
legit yeah he's got an alpha brain on an
iv drip yeah right into his dick hole
he's going slower now because remember
he used to be fast
he doesn't have a stutter you know he's
always had like a bit of an issue
what's the thing it's like aren't we
like
i don't know i just it's so depressing
that these people rule us but then you
also go
who even wants this [ __ ] job and if
you if you're really talented and you
don't even want that job who wants that
[ __ ] job i mean look at this one
she's
indian she's black she doesn't know what
she is she's everything
best for their health their well-being
and for their families
that's what real leadership looks like
and when joe talks about his priorities
he knows and he cares about the fact
that we have as a nation
witnessed a hundred and sixty five
thousand people who just in the last
few months have died in our country we
know that those individuals represent
families loved ones grandparents
parents sisters and brothers aunts and
uncles
sisters those are all people she could
have put in jail
she's so upset she because we could have
put handcuffs on all of those people
out there fighting wildfires they could
have been working for a walmart for
10 cents an hour in the kamala harris
prison program
yeah you know what are you going to do
it's just um it's just wild
that these are uh our choices trump
or this crew or this uh old fella but
that's what i mean it's like this is
kind of the beginning of the
she makes sense to me as a vice
president like you know yeah
get away from all the prisons she makes
all the right people feel comfortable
yeah she makes all the right like all
the people that need
uh somebody in there that will you know
check the boxes check all the boxes
yeah and uh who's that guy
i don't like him
who is he i don't know what does donald
trump say
oh he's wearing a mask yeah we unite
night in our effort defeat invisible
china virus
and many people say that it is patriotic
to wear a face mask when you can't
socially distance
there is nobody more patriotic than me
your favorite president
yeah this is the end i mean this is the
end this is
out of a movie
you